[Music]
hi my name is Jimmy I'm the chef at
Madame beau fuzz a staple dish in
Vietnam we all love pho because it's
food for the Soul and I just I have to
eat for like at least once a week
there's different regions in Vietnam
that there's so many different
variations everyone has their own
version
ours is a southern style so it's a
little bit on the sweeter side there's
also a northern style which is a little
bit saltier and they may not have all
the garnishes that we use all the
recipes came down from my mom my
grandmother and we'd like to eat it very
rich so we add short rib and I would say
it's a American version of you know pho
on steroids
[Music]
the best way to eat your boffo
is when it's piping hot you know you
want to sweat it out while you're eating
it when you get the broth you want to
taste and you want to smell all the
spices and all those notes have to hit
your taste buds perfectly we try to
capture all the elements of the beat so
it's on a really really low boil and we
cook all the meats down that's how we
keep our brisket soft but we cook our
short rib fall off the bone and all that
takes time so our broth is cooked 24
hours and after the meats are done the
spices go into the broth we start off
with charring onions ginger and shallots
and then star nice cinnamon cardamon
coriander seeds and fennel seed without
the broth there's nothing right there's
no music to dance to
[Music]
the garnish just comes on the side and
that's an extra crunch to the bra I like
to add my bean sprouts in first because
I like the soup to cook the bean sprouts
some people like it crunch here I like
my bean sprouts cooked after I would add
basil some people like peppers and spice
some people don't but I always add
everything and I always squeeze a dash
of lime just to give it that extra kick
in the broth when I start off with my
boffo I like to eat the noodles first
just to see the texture and taste it
with the broth this is a rice noodle
there's different textures but our
restaurant we like to use the thinner
ones and because we buy our noodles
fresh we just dip it in the water
five seconds pull it out strain it and
you're done I always add sriracha and
hoisin I like to do a 50/50 mix because
it gives you like a little bit sweet and
spicy at the same time but I only use it
just to dip my meats we have Angus beef
round-eye we usually put it raw and the
soup does the cooking beef brisket and
we also have our homemade beef meatballs
and of course you can't miss this this
is the short rib as you can see it just
and this is the best part of the bra and
this one makes them wrong
great I always just dig in because our
bulls are are really Hardy as you can
see there's like moo everywhere so the
best way to eat it is with some meat
some onions some noodles at the same
time
what's with some broth so everything in
this spoon is a party my mom would
always have a lot of people over and
cook bowls of love and like food is food
is just a symbol of love right like it
brings everyone together and I was the
only child so I would always have to
help clean help prep for her and
everything that I learned today as a
chef is from my mom and my mom's kitchen
we're not doing anything fancy we're
just doing home-cooked meals
mom grandma style you know and we want
you to feel like you're at home here
in a sense
you